[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm justine and i'm adam and today we
have the honor of introducing you to
warcraft
[Music]
so what is this game what is this game
is a mobile strategy fast-paced hero
collector and villain collective and
villain collector game that has a vast
pve campaign it also has dungeons and
raids and pvp and co-op and everything
you'd expect of a warcraft game from
blizzard we love games we were super
inspired by tower defense games our game
isn't really tower defense it's more our
style to do a tower offense game
it's joyful chaos
and we're aiming to bring our blizzard
best to mobile games that inspire us
chaos range all the chaos can't use
chaos twice
[Music]
in basements of taverns all across
azeroth a mysterious machine has been
found is it new has it always been there
powered by gnomish engineering and
arclight
this machine has been generating famous
and infamous battlegrounds for your
entertainment so when the battle begins
you'll come to the battlefield with your
army ready to go assault a boss
there's a base for you to defend if the
base dies your run is over also there's
meeting stones on the map if we control
the meeting stone we can play things
closer to the boss if the enemy controls
the meeting stone they're gonna come at
us a little bit closer as well there's
also towers on the map for you to go
capture that lets you have a forward
position so you can assault the boss
directly there's also shinies that you
can get there's gold nodes and treasure
chests to plunder you gotta get the
shiny give me the shiny
the more gold that you can get the more
chaos you can reign upon the field
one of my favorite things about this
game is that every mini has their own
personality and every single one of them
thinks they're the coolest
and they're all wrong except for
blackrock pyromancer
in warcraft arclight rumble we have five
families the alliance
the noble alliance with a lot of
defensive units and spells
there's also the poured
the proud horde that will overpower your
enemies
but there's also black rock
to sear a hole in your enemy's defenses
like throw down
there's of course the
undead
you can bring a skeleton of troops to
the battlefield
and beast
we also have a literal stampede from the
plains and jungles of azeroth
with all of the chaos going on with the
troops we need somebody to lead this
rabble leaders are a way to cater your
strategy and build a specific play style
that suits you if you want to play siege
units go for snead
snead has a trait called sneeds greed
that makes all of your siege units grab
extra gold
my personal favorite is rend
with his ability black in the sky
it makes all of your flying units one
gold cheaper so you can fill the air
with chaos
there are tons of strategies that you
can assemble with this there are over 60
minis for you to play with but you don't
need to have an understanding of
warcraft to be able to embrace the chaos
a sense of exploration and wonder should
come across regardless speaking of
wonder let's go play a game we're gonna
do it live i mean it'll be edited later
but that's okay welcome to ginrok's
swell troll aisle a taste of strength
this is a fun map because i did the
design for it and justine did the art
we'd have our animators and our
character artists to make all this
happen there's so many people that go
into making this a reality the goal of
the swole troll patrol is to punch your
base in the face smash that start button
let's go
okay
here comes a troll he's coming down our
lane and the first thing we're gonna do
is have some harpies go say hello
there's a kobold that's already trying
to steal gold over there we're gonna let
him go for that though there's a bat
rider coming and we have a huntress
let's play a huntress to help this out a
little bit and here comes another swole
troll let's send out some chickens to
meet that smultro but those trolls are
definitely relentless
i'm actually gonna lose
we don't make these maps to be easy i
thought you said you couldn't lose you
designed this map
smash that start button let's go all
right here comes this swirl troll and we
need some harpies to go take care of
that swole troll
there's some chickens coming i don't
care about those chickens but that
kobold i do that kobold definitely needs
to get out of here
need some more gold though let's go mine
this area right here so that we can fuel
our harpy addiction all right good have
those chickens come in and peck that
swole troll
just like it's a snack oh my gosh look
at all of these units coming in here but
one chain lightning is all we need
[Music]
hopefully that cobalt sneaks by ah
there you go
over time oh we're in overtime all right
down to the wires
come on
time's running out too close all right
all right all right let's do a wombo
combo
[Applause]
that's just one of the 70 plus maps that
we have for you to play all over azeroth
one of my favorite maps is going back to
stranglethorn deep in the jungle is
gurabashi arena king mukhla is there
with his banan chucks and banandalia
there's a couple of apes in unguro that
have some banana almonds we've got the
bernini gun by uk luck um girl also has
devil sore queen
the tyrant of the area and she comes
stomping down and you just have to take
her down before she bites your base
tasty base
there's always going to be unique
challenges depending on each map when it
comes to maps that require you to be
able to take charge of the high ground
or combat massive cannon bombardment
from a ship there's so many ways that
you can customize your minis using
talent
their abilities can be augmented in all
different sorts of directions maeve has
a really awesome talent called cloak of
shadows wherever you play her on the map
she will cast smoke bomb and stealth
everything around her so you can make a
mobile assault squad anywhere on the map
[Music]
this game has so many ways to play
varied content every single day every
single week you get to play a new
dungeon every week we did talk about
dungeons we didn't talk about dungeons
you can play dungeon solo or if you want
to play co-op you can as well we didn't
talk about co-op i forgot to talk about
co-op co-op you can join a guild you can
play with your friends you can join a
guild and you can fight your friends
fight fight fight you can go play raids
with them there's so many things to do
in this game we didn't talk about race
you're just gonna have to stay tuned for
more information aren't you closebid is
coming to limited regions soon so keep
an eye on social media for more
information
on behalf of the team we are so excited
for you guys to get your hands on this
and we really really look forward to
your feedback and input thank you so
much for hanging out with us enjoy the
joy enjoy the chaos the chaos
it never ends
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
for ceremony
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
what's the plans
[Music]
[Music]
you